comment imaginez-vous le futur
argy peut-être que vous êtes déjà dit ce
serait bien si
centrales à charbon si on fermer toutes
les centrales nucléaires même et qu'on
en place et où sa part du renouvelable
mais là blanc d'entre vous vous êtes
vous avez peut-être dit c'est juste un
rêve
ça n'arrivera jamais c'est une belle
idée peut-être mais c'est tout et si ça
n'était pas qu'un rêve
s'il y avait un moyen d'en faire une
réalité si je vous disais que c'était
possible
comment réagiriez-vous montmorillon
drake locaux et aujourd'hui je vais vous
faire une petite histoire de l'énergie
d'après vous d'où vient l'énergie que
nous consommons d'où vient-elle vraiment
pour le voir nous de vous remonter le
temps nous devons rue bruce et le temps
pour voir d'où viennent vraiment les
choses commençons par les voitures les
voitures que nous conduisons tous les
voitures c'est du carburant de l'essence
les sens c'est du pétrole le pétrole
vient de sous la terre ça jusque là
c'est assez facile mais le pétrole
lui-même il a des millions d'années
c'était autre chose c'était de la
biomasse la biomasse des cadavres
d'animaux et de plantes qui sont ont
atterri au fond des océans des
tourbières et c'est que ces animaux ont
tiré leur énergie des plantes et les
plantes
du coup tiré leur énergie in fine et du
soleil le pétrole c'est l'énergie
solaire stockée sur des millions
d'années
on se rendait pas compte en fait la
plupart du temps c'est pour ça que
j'avais besoin de cette image
prenons une autre énergie par jan aps le
vent et une zone chaude une zone froide
une zone la plus haute pression culotte
que l'autre mais ces zones sont chauffés
elle aussi par le soleil finalement les
l'énergie éolienne c'est aussi du de
l'énergie solaire avec un petit
différend
maintenant prenons l'énergie
houlomotrice encore une forme d'énergie
mais encore ça vient du vent et encore
ça vient du soleil finalement c'est la
même chose on en revient toujours au
même
et maintenant le nucléaire vous vous me
direz nucléaire c'est plus compliqué oui
mais en fait ça vient aussi des étoiles
démonstration
le nucléaire en fait c'est l'uranium
l'uranium en fait était dans la croûte
terrestre depuis des millions d'années
même des milliards d'années en fait et
il n'a pas bougé parce que c'est un
élément chimique vous ne faites pas le
détruire pas comme ça il ne peut que des
trucs tout seul en faisant des
attractions une désintégration
radioactive est en fait il est amené là
par quoi bas par les météorites qui ont
formé la terre ya des milliards d'années
c'est de là que ça vient et ces
météorites elle même j'ai des nuages
interstellaires et dans les nuages
interstellaires
il ya eu des événements cataclysmiques
il ya des milliards d'années les
supernovas l'ultime feu d'une étoile sur
le point de mourir elle convertit toute
son énergie elle consomme 10 q 150 atom
en l'espace de quelques secondes l ex
plus sa matière jusqu'aux confins du
système solaire environnants des
événements cataclysmiques et son produit
pas souvent et ces explosions viennent
des étoiles les étoile comme le soleil
l'uranium
c'est la mort d'une étoile stockées sur
des milliards d'années pour recréer
l'uranium
il faut tuer d'autres étoiles maintenant
peut-être que vous avez une idée d' avec
quoi on joue avec une claire voilà mais
il donc si on regarde jusqu'à maintenant
on a eu le solaire à débit direct le
solaire et l'éolien on a le solaire
stockée sur l'échelle d'une vie humaine
la biomasse stockées sur des échasses
géologiques comme comme les
hydrocarbures est stockée sur une
échelle encore plus longue
les le nucléaire maintenant il ya
d'autres formes d'énergie nucléaire il y
à l'énergie de fusion nucléaire
qu'est ce que c'est la fusion nucléaire
c'est l'homme qui prend le soleil le
mets sur terre le met dans une boîte et
dit qu'il pense le contrôler ça peut
marcher ça peut vraiment marché en fait
ça on devient un dieu soit on devient
quelqu'un de très dangereux et entre les
deux ça va dépendre de ce qui va se
passer
et qu'est ce que c'est la fusion
nucléaire ne vous avez d hydrogène lourd
c'est ce qui va se passer dans le
réacteur iter à cadarache du deutérium
et de tritium qui fusionnent pour former
un atome à noyaux d'hélium et un neutron
à cause de ce neutrons les parois du
réacteur vont devenir radioactives
du coup ça produit des déchets
radioactif le tritium lui-même hydrogène
lourd à 3 nucléons est aussi radioactifs
finalement c'est pas là mais la solution
ultime
si on veut aller plus loin il faut aller
à 600 millions de degrés non pas 100
millions il faut encore qu'on finisse le
placement cinq cent fois mieux qu'on
sait le faire
et là on arrive à la fusion de bord
hydrogène une fusion qui ne consomment
pas d'éléments radioactifs et qui n'en
produit pas non plus avec ça on aura
vraiment une énergie du futur le plus
grands magiciens et sorciers sont
tentera de mettre tout leur savoir pour
essayer de nous donner cette technologie
mais ça pourrait prendre très très
longtemps peut-être jamais alors en
attendant on fait quoi
parce qu en attendant le pétrole
continue de brûler en sentant tout au
plus on aura converti l'essentiel de nos
réserves d'hydrocarbures en dioxyde de
carbone finalement en 200 ans on aura
dilapidé les ressources qui ont mis des
millions d'années as créé pour donner
une idée de ce que ça représente
imaginez un fils de famille riche qui
dilapiderait l'argent de trois
générations
en quelques heures stade vrai ça alors
comment est-ce qu'on peut arrêter de
vivre à crédit un crédit qu'on ne peut
pas rembourser
la seule solution serait du coup de
prendre du solaire à débit direct de ne
plus prendre de crédit de prendre du
solaire photovoltaïque ou de prendre de
l'éolien qu'elle élargit solairedirect
aussi mais seulement vous vous dites je
vois venir des panneaux solaires sais
rien un panneau solaire c'est tellement
plus petit que 120 nucléaire cela ne
sera jamais qu'une goutte d'eau
finalement on pourrait très bien rester
plus nucléaire c'est pas si grave les
voitures pu beaucoup moins aujourd'hui
que le pays il ya 20 ans et c'est donc
finalement c'est pas la peine de changer
tout ira bien
tout finira par s'arranger si vous
croyez ça c'est que vous êtes resté dans
un monde de rêve
le monde a beaucoup changé ces dernières
années et il ya peut-être quelques ya
peut-être des choses que vous n'avez pas
vu venir
voici le monde tel qu'il est aujourd'hui
75 mégawatts d'éolien déployés aux états
unis 100 gigawatts de solaire qui vont
se déployer en inde d'ici 2022 150
gigawatts d'éolien qui sont déjà
déployés en chine avec un an 3 gigawatts
de solaire à titre de comparaison la
puissance totale du monde c'est de tera
watt donc 2000 giga watts finalement
c'est pas tant que ça et aussi un
dernier chiffre le solaire l'énergie
solaire qui vient sur terre chaque
seconde
c'est 65 pétards watts 105000 térawatts
donc finalement ce que ça veut dire
c'est qu'avec 0 01 % de la surface de la
terre avec du photovoltaïque 300 à 200
km dansaert à vous alimenter le monde
entier en électricité finalement c'est
pas grand chose
du coup ça marche mais alors comment on
en est arrivé là
le solaire était pourtant si petit
seulement vous avez négligé un paramètre
le paramètre économique
c'est pas grave si une centrale prend
plus de place du moment que la place est
encore réaliste l'important c'est
qu'elle coûte moins cher finalement ce
grand démon de l'économie qui nous a
infligé la creuse et 2008 pourrait très
bien être celui qui nous sauve du
pétrole parce qu'en 2025 mais centrale
solaire sera déjà moins cher qu'une
centrale au charbon
même la chine va se mettre au soleil
elle le fait déjà d'ailleurs seulement
il ya un problème
l'énergie solaire telle qu'elle est
soumise à une limite une limite qu'elle
veut pas dépasser si on est femme en
l'état c'est 30 % de notre énergie 30%
en énergie du monde seulement peuvent
être fournis en sus du solaire pourquoi
allons voir pour ça cette fois nous
devons aller dans le futur imaginons un
monde 100 % renouvelable
les écolos ont gagné vous êtes chez vous
il fait beau il fait chaud
enfin comme aujourd'hui le soleil se
couche
l'air est immobile la nuit tombe vous
voulez allumer les lumières mais ça ne
marche pas à rennes se passe pourquoi
donc
eh bien vous l'avez probablement déjà
deviné lorsque le soleil se couche et le
vent tombe les sources d'énergie
renouvelables ne produisent plus rien et
le stock rien elles doivent fournir tout
ce qu'elles ont produit à l'instant le
produit du coup la lumière s'éteint chez
vous et le problème c'est que c'est pas
seulement chez vous c'est dans toute
l'europe
touteleurope ton dans la nuit en même
temps et toutes leurs options dans des
trous de vent de 30 jours tous les ans
où elles produisent seulement 25% de la
capacité de ces parcs éoliens du coup il
ya des moments où il n'y a pas d'énergie
renouvelable produite alors qu alors que
peut-on faire
le problème donc est un problème non pas
de production mais de moments de
production si seulement on pouvait faire
briller le soleil la nuit mais peut-être
qu'en fait il suffit juste de fournir
cette énergie la nuit la solution était
sous nos yeux c'est le stockage énergie
stocker l'énergie solaire la journée
pour la restituer la nuit
stocker l'énergie éolienne pour la
restituer pendant les nuits sans vent
grâce au stockage d'énergie
on peut passer de 30 % à 100 %
l'énergie renouvelable c'est ça le
chaînon manquant
mais alors stocker l'énergie on sait
déjà faire edf d'ailleurs a installé six
gigawatts de barrage en double un
barrage auront un barrage au bas qui se
passe de l'eau qui descendent de l'eau
quand on a besoin en électricité qui est
la remonte quand on a trop d'électricité
ça marche très bien depuis 50 ans le
problème c'est quand vous n'avez plus de
rivière à exploiter ou qu'en tout
simplement votre vie au milieu d'une
plaine
là ça ne marche plus donc il faut autre
chose alors je vois venir une énorme
batterie au lithium qu'est ce que ça
donnerait et bassa de problème ça coûte
cher et aussi les matériaux les
matériaux sont toxiques et inflammables
on peut faire mieux avec de l'air
comprimé la comprimer isotherme ses 25
ans durée de vie de fond marcheurs que
lithium pas de matières toxiques 100%
recyclable une solution pour l'avenir
parmi d'autres pour vera qui vont verra
qui va gagner maintenant grâce à une
bonne techno stockage pour qu'on réalise
on brise la limite des 30 %
on brise un ami et 30% donc on peut
monter à 100% d'énergies renouvelables
dans le monde avant même de découvrir
les réacteurs à fusion nucléaire
on pourra même ensuite générer des
carburants à partir de cette énergie
renouvelable on pourra mettre du fer du
méthane et de l'hydrogène de synthèse
alexa on pourra alimenter des voitures
comme aujourd'hui sauf qu'on leur a fait
à partir de dioxyde de carbone qu'on
aura capturés donc on sera enfin en ces
mots que nous y circulaient enfin toute
notre énergie primaire viendra du soleil
en débit direct plus de dettes on
arrêtera de vivre avec des dettes qu'on
ne peut rembourser
on rendra une terre à nos enfants n'ont
pas ravagé
mais tel qu'on l'a trouvé on pourra
découvrir le voyage interstellaire et
découvrir d'autres civilisations non pas
pour les piller et prendre tout ce qu'il
a sur la planète mais en revenant en
paix au final l'humanité aura atteint
l'âge de raison
énergétique nous n'aurons plus dansant
en mai dans un million d'années
si l'on prend la bonne voie aujourd'hui
merci
[Applaudissements]